oh
[Musique]
quand j'ai vu la photo je suis tout de
suite que cet enfant et à ma nièce ou
cette fillette s'appelle amira elle
aurait dû grandir avec sa famille à
toronto mais son père a choisi de
quitter le canada pour aller faire le
djihad en syrie avec sa femme
amira est née après il y a quatre ans
dans une ville tenue par le groupe armé
état islamique
sa vie est devenue un véritable enfer
sa maison a été détruite par des frappes
aériennes
son père sa mère ses frères et soeurs
ils sont tous morts sous ses yeux un
danger
on l'a retrouvée seule au bord d'une
route road l'oncle d'amira vit à toronto
il nous a demandé l'anonymat par peur de
représailles contre lui même et ses
proches
ce mairie c'est très dur toute notre
famille vit dans l'angoissé m'attendre
et je ne sais pas comment va ma petite
nièce physiquement et mentalement je ne
sais pas si quelqu'un veille sur elle si
elle mange correctement si elle prend
des vitamines
je ne sais rien de tout ça
[Musique]
amira vie dans le camp à lol où sont
entassées 70000 personnes qui vivent
dans des conditions extrêmement
l'organisme humanitaire internationale
save the children est une des rares ong
sur place
l'épidémie de grippe de à toute clause
de rougeole ça devient de plus en plus
dangereux l'organisme canadien fèves
estime qu'il y à 45 e canadiens détenus
dans le cas à lol dont 25 enfants
sow
c'est l'organisme que dirige alexandra
ben qui avait d'abord obtenu cette photo
d'amira et qui l'a transmise à son oncle
il avait déjà cette première photo de la
petite prise à l'âge de deux ans il a
tout de suite su qu'il s'agissait de sa
nièce
né en territoire syrien et comme elle
est née de parents canadiens
il a contacté sa députée fédérale puis
des fonctionnaires d'affaires mondial
canada pour la faire rapatrier au plus
tôt il explique qui s'est heurtée à un
dédale administratif
les gens d'affaires mondial m'ont dit
qu'ils ne pouvaient rien faire parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de service consulaire
dans cette région mais que si je pouvais
moi trouver le moyen de l'amener jusqu'à
la frontière
il pourrait nous aider par la suite
l'oncle a essayé de se rendre sur place
pour la ramener mais la situation est
trop dangereuse surtout depuis le départ
des américains de la zone kurde
je leur ai proposé plusieurs options je
leur ai dit s'il ya des raisons
politiques qui vous empêche d'intervenir
on peut agir discrètement j'ai même
faire les autorités kurdes demande que
le gouvernement canadien reconnaissent
formellement l'identité et la
citoyenneté d'amira avant de la conduire
à la frontière faible de le faire mais
ça se fait il ya d'autres pays qui l'ont
fait il ya plusieurs pays la belgique
l'italie l'australie l'allemagne qui ont
réussi rapatrient leurs enfin ça se fait
il faut avoir la volonté politique est
prêt mais changer interrogé à ce sujet à
l'émission me dit est faux de radio
canada le ministre champagne a laissé la
porte ouverte à une intervention qui
connaît poste dossier en particulier
vous savez carmes affaires consulaires
on est toujours prudent parce qu'une
question de confidentialité vous ceci
pour respecter
les informations personnelles mais
certainement c'est quelque chose que je
vais manquer rire pour voir ce que le
canada peut faire cet avocat à
l'immigration représentent d'autres
familles canadiennes qui souhaite
rapatrier leurs petits enfants des camps
syriennes et des journalistes qui sont
sur le terrain et mais le gouvernement
canadien ne leur offre aucune aide à eux
non plus pour obtenir des documents
requis ce n'est que politique
les enfants n'ont rien demandé ils sont
nés dans ce pays il dans les conditions
qu'on connaît ils sont canadiens le
canada des obligations envers ces
enfants là il doit g et dois-je et
maintenant on ne devrait pas mêler la
politique à tout ça c'est une enfant de
4 ans quel crime peut-elle avoir commis
à son âge et pourtant elle est détenue
dans une prison malgré les revers et les
frustrations l'oncle d'amira persiste
l'attitude actuelle du gouvernement
canadien n'est pas digne des valeurs
historiques de mon pays d'adoption
dit-il en afghanistan ne vais pas
m'arrêter
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit rentrée je me
fous des conséquences et du temps que ça
prendra
je veux juste continuer à avancer
[Musique]